hey everyone thanks for watching my  videos and thanks for tuning in but  unfortunately this is this doesn't have  an intro and everything just because  it's a short hd test i'm trying to see  if i can get this new digital camera to  record and upload to youtube in hd so  you'll likely see more than one copy of  this video if you've subscribed already  but i'm going to try to get um i'm going  to stop doing this when i get the hd  link under the video so um comment if it  is an hd or if it's an hq and i'm going  to get a camcorder for this because it's  annoying having to hold it and shake it  all the time so yeah thanks for watching  this one and it's just a straight upload  so peace